[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález finalizó el mes
de junio el mes del orgullo y como
siempre estas conmemoraciones nos llevan
a hacer balance sobre todo en américa
latina que tiene muchas contradicciones
porque es la región con las tasas más
altas de violencia contra la comunidad
lgbt
+ o plus pero también tiene algunas de
las leyes más progresistas más avanzadas
si se compara con otras regiones para la
igualdad y la protección está disparidad
es solamente digamos que la punta del
iceberg es el inicio de una problemática
y de hechos muy complicados por ser
sociedades muy conservadoras poco
tolerantes y con una disparidad
estructural a todo nivel así vivimos en
américa latina por ejemplo veamos
algunos datos hablando de violencia
puntualmente sólo entre el 2014 y el
2020 1 3514 personas de este colectivo
fueron asesinadas de ellas unos 1400
personas estaban relacionadas con
prejuicios con ataques relacionados con
prejuicios para el 2020 que es el año de
la pandemia del cob y 19
con 351 víctimas mortales relacionadas
con este colectivo países como colombia
méxico y honduras concentran el 89 por
ciento del total de las víctimas en
brasil
allí fueron reportadas 175 víctimas
todas ellas eran mujeres trans las
cifras de colombia son completamente
escandalosas son 524 asesinatos mexico
402 honduras 164 nos falta mucho para
educar nos falta mucho por aprender en
la región para avanzar en la igualdad en
cuanto a los derechos porque miren
también el ejemplo que les tenemos acá
las parejas y las relaciones de parejas
del mismo sexo siguen siendo un delito o
son penadas en al menos nueve países de
américa latina y el caribe en suramérica
destacamos a guyana que tiene una ley
muy restrictiva en el caribe hay que
destacar el caso de jamaica también hay
varios estados allí en las antillas que
tienen legislaciones similares
solamente cuatro países bolivia ecuador
cuba y méxico protegen a las personas
lgbt de manera puntual en la
constitución de sus países hay un
artículo allí que lo específica mientras
que el matrimonio entre parejas del
mismo sexo como ustedes ven en el mapa
es reconocido en apenas siete países
argentina uruguay brasil ecuador
colombia costa rica y en algunos estados
de la república mexicana entre ellos en
la ciudad de mexico la capital
chile y bolivia usted los ve nice de
color amarillo allí reconocen las
uniones civiles precisamente chile
allí la ley que permite el matrimonio
igualitario está haciendo curso en el
congreso y es un proyecto que es
impulsado por el propio gobierno del
presidente sebastián piñera para
terminar 11 estados de américa latina
del caribe al menos reconocen las
agresiones contra las personas diversas
como crímenes de odio y sólo hay 14
países en donde hay una ley que permite
proteger la discriminación laboral hay
avances pero aún falta todos estos datos
los pueden encontrar en la página web de
france 24 en un completo artículo de
nuestra compañera más
está allí publicado en unos minutos se
los dejo a través de mi cuenta de
twitter
santi lobos para analizar este tema
entonces hemos invitado a colette
espinet muñoz núñez perdón ella es
cofundadora y secretaria general de la
red corporal en libertad que es una red
internacional de trabajo de personas
lgtb y también personas privadas de
libertad
ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
montevideo la capital uruguaya y también
está con nosotros natalia jiménez ella
es coordinadora general de musaví que es
un espacio latinoamericano de
sexualidades y derechos ella se
encuentra en centroamérica en la ciudad
de san josé en costa rica pura vida
ustedes también en nuestros televidentes
son parte de esta conversación a través
de las redes sociales pueden dejar todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas en las
cuentas de facebook de twitter y de
instagram estamos como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
deje los comentarios con el numeral el
debate efe 24 precisamente el equipo de
redes me hace caer en cuenta que hay en
este momento una encuesta en línea para
que ustedes respondan allí relacionado
con
un proyecto de ley en españa llamado la
ley trans que permite entre otras
acciones que las personas puedan
modificar su sexo en el documento de
identidad pueden dejar también allí sus
comentarios qué opinan de esta noticia
pues ya tenemos a los invitados tenemos
también el tema tenemos el contexto y
pues quiero comenzar entonces con el
cole está en la ciudad de montevideo
preguntándole en el 2021 en junio en
pleno invierno austral para ustedes allí
en la capital uruguaya donde estamos
desde qué punto de la montaña estamos
mirando desde la parte intermedia
todavía desde la parte del valle mirando
hacia arriba y ya estamos llegando a la
cima usted qué piensa
bueno muy buenas noches que me escucha
vida perfecto adelante
muy buenas noches bueno primero que nada
gracias por permitirme estar en este
espacio y más aún en compañía de una
hermana de lucha amiga del alma como es
la talla de nes
yo dirijo en el uruguay soy directora
nacional de una organización que
trabajamos a nivel nacional como estamos
en uruguay en este junio frío muy frío
julio muy frío
estamos en la mitad de la montaña
si bien uruguay tiene
leyes que reconocen derechos de
vanguardia a nivel mundial también
tenemos que decir que el contexto de la
pandemia y el contexto político en el
que uruguay se encuentra hoy ha logrado
un retroceso en derecho pero sí un
estancamiento en derecho eso qué
significa nosotros por ejemplo tenemos
la ley integral de las personas trans
donde se reconocen los derechos de las
personas trans en salud de educación
cultura cambio de nombre y género
etcétera pero el gobierno no votó
presupuesto
e implementar todas las políticas
sociales que tienen que ver con los
derechos de la comunidad trans eso
significa que por ejemplo la ley
específica que el estado debe encargarse
de la salud integral de las personas
trans en forma gratuita al no haber
presupuesto por el estar no se encarga
de la salud en este momento nosotros
desde ese te busqué en mi organización
de base estamos repartiendo canastas
alimenticias a 367 personas trans en el
uruguay
estamos existiendo en constantes
violencias abusos policiales
desalojos quienes estamos en la mitad
hemos reconocido derechos y estos
derechos han sido reconocidos gracias a
la lucha de las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil pero esos derechos están
estancados y acá también hay elementos
nuevos que empezaron a aparecer en
latinoamérica y el caribe como lo son
grupos anti derecho las iglesias
neopentecostales la derecha política las
pandillas y los asesinatos que podemos
trabajo hoy es así la realidad en
latinoamérica y dar y si con las gracias
por este panorama general de la
situación desde su perspectiva entonces
estamos en la mitad de la montaña vamos
a ver qué dice en la talla en san josé
en costa rica que perspectiva hay desde
allí desde centroamérica tal vez una
región mucho más conservadora que el
cono sur mucho más conservadora que
suramérica en general como ven ustedes
allí la situación en general del
colectivo lgtb
y luego ya nos vamos a meter en puntos
en cuanto a la legislación y ya los
avances que ha habido a nivel sanitario
también en diferentes países
bueno sí respondió a su pregunta que en
cual estado en esta montaña estábamos en
la región centroamericana
estamos en el sótano no ni siquiera que
hay como hay como un hundimiento allí
todavía mayor este si hablamos de la
región centroamericana en general porque
este todavía faltan muchos derechos por
reconocer existen como bien lo decía
usted en ese informe lo que llaman el
triángulo norte en centroamérica es de
las zonas más peligrosas sobre todo para
las poblaciones que el lp y muestra de
eso es como también se viene dando mucha
migración forzada este desde estos
países hacia el norte sobre todo méxico
y estados unidos en busca de una mejor
calidad de vida este y en este trayecto
muchas personas de los llamamos
diversidad sexual porque es un riesgo
que diversidad sexual somos todos todos
y todos éste han muerto en este camino
tomando en cuenta según el informe de
homofobia estado de la asociación
internacional de gays
el mundo todavía en 70 países en el
mundo
siguen habiendo legislaciones normativas
que van contrarias a nuestras
identidades expresiones orientaciones y
características sexuales como vimos se
nos decía entre entre 7 y 9 países que
todavía siguen teniendo incluso
penalidades más fuertes hasta con penas
de muerte para personas que son de lo
que llamamos diversidad sexual pero si
nos enfocamos en la región todavía este
la mayoría de personas trans no cuentan
con ninguna garantía de derechos y sí
pero si hablamos de costa rica sería
como un país sui generis en la región y
como bien nos decía cuál de estos
avances se han dado gracias a el
esfuerzo al trabajo de las
organizaciones y activistas que es
durante muchos años han venido luchando
para que esto se garantice siempre nos
pone un ejemplo como por ejemplo con lo
de la corte el fallo en la opinión
consultiva de la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos
pero esto también es gracias al trabajo
que hemos venido haciendo las
organizaciones no solo a favor del
matrimonio civil igualitario sino este
pueblo de la estela garantía de las
identidades de género a través de una
ley que inclusive mi organización
presenta ante la asamblea legislativa y
que inspira
precisamente esta consulta ante la corte
y le quitó un último segundo es que
últimamente se ha dado también un fallo
hablando de la corte a favor de un caso
en honduras que precisamente cuando éste
hubo un toque de queda en honduras el
primer día de toque de queda matan a una
chica trans y la corte falla a favor con
algunas observaciones de algunos de los
jueces y tal vez lo podríamos tocar más
adelante me sorprendió un poco que estoy
hablando con dos personas que están en
tal vez dos de los países que más han
avanzado en términos de legislación y en
derechos para este colectivo como son
uruguay y costa rica cada uno en sus
distintos niveles y en sus respectivas
regiones
y entonces me lleva a pensar que puede
uno esperar en las otras regiones en el
norte de suramérica o en el centro del
continente
si ustedes ven el panorama todavía tan
difuso con esa luz al final del túnel
todavía tan lejana y que los avances
todavía no están permitiendo que los
estigmas se quiten es un arraigo que
trae la sociedad latinoamericana y que
se siga todavía estigmatizando a este
colectivo como empezar entonces a partir
de lo ganado empezar a quitar esos
estigmas y empezar a avanzar o todavía
américa latina sigue siendo
exageradamente conservadora hago la
ronda a la inversa con la talla en san
jose
gracias en el lópez es que precisamente
tenemos que empezar con eso con la
educación este sobre estos temas todavía
se siguen tratando como temas tabú como
temas de los que no se puede hablar y en
la medida en que no hablemos de esto se
siguen generando precisamente como vimos
te lo decía estigma y discriminación
hacia nuestros pobres en nuestras
poblaciones de nada sirve a pesar de
todo lo que hemos luchado
normativas a favor de nuestras
poblaciones si la población en general
todavía sigue esté discriminando
marginando y segregando a nuestras
poblaciones y se ensaña sobre todo en la
población trans de hombres y mujeres
trans por eso es que el promedio de vida
por ejemplo en centroamérica es entre 28
y 32 años y tiene mucho que ver con esa
violencia generalizada que hay hacia
nuestras poblaciones en la medida en que
no se hable no se eduque sobre estos
temas y no quiero decir que se normalice
pero si ese sensibilizar a la población
sobre estas otras realidades se van a
seguir dando este tipo de violencias
hacia nuestras poblaciones
muestra de eso este argentino fue uno de
los primeros países junto con uruguay en
generar leyes por ejemplo de identidad
de género y antes y a pesar de la ley de
entidades género todavía se siguen
grabando crímenes también en el mismo
argentina hacia las poblaciones trans
colecta en montevideo su opinión
bueno yo creo que lo que no lo que
tenemos que dar es la batalla cultural
latinoamérica y el caribe están
intersección analizadas por una cantidad
de poblaciones que son constantemente
discriminadas estigmatizado
la colonización impuso en latinoamérica
el desarraigo de lo indígena lo
afrodescendiente como esclavo e impuso
el pensamiento judeocristiano del
binario
este pensamiento del binarismo y de que
si sos de te blanca y sos varón tenéis
todos los derechos y lo que hoy por hoy
hace que todos aquellos cuerpos
disidentes todos aquellos cuerpos que no
estén dentro de lo esperado dentro de la
norma y por lo tanto no se pueden
dominar porque están desafiando la norma
sean expulsados de la sociedad y se les
ha que los derechos no se les permitan
los derechos por lo tanto tenemos un
gran desafío que es el cambio cultural y
en ese desafío
tenemos que pensar
toda esta normatividad que responde al
poder
blanco al poder capitalista al
neoliberalismo
toda esa normativa únicamente favorece a
quien está dentro de la norma y quien se
amolda de la norma entonces las personas
de la comunidad lgtb
cuanto más pobres somos cuanto más
indígenas somos cuanto más
afrodescendientes somos a menos derechos
accedemos porque estamos de alguna
manera desafiando el poder estamos
resistiendo el poder estamos
transgrediendo el poder entonces ese
conservadurismo no permite el
reconocimiento de los derechos si con el
cambio cultural unas palabras claves que
usted ha dicho en su intervención cambio
cultural eso me lleva a pensar que
estamos hablando también de educación
reforzar valores en educación que nos
lleven a tolerancia y a tener un poco
apertura de mente y b1 por ejemplo el
caso de
colombia que es donde está aquí la base
de france 24 en español en un país donde
hubo una controversia muy grande
precisamente por el diseño de unas de un
programa educacional para las escuelas
de primaria para hablar precisamente de
la identidad sexual y hablar de la
diversidad sexual y esta ideología de
género fue usada políticamente
precisamente para señalar para atacar y
se generó una gran controversia y el
resultado es que esto quedó helado
cuando era un gran paso precisamente en
ese cambio cultural en esa educación en
esa tolerancia la sociedad todavía no
está preparada para dar estos pasos o
esas batallas siguen siendo muy
difíciles todo en este colectivo es
difícil lograr para tal parece
exactamente todo en este colectivo es
lograr la talla decía recién en
centroamérica hay las personas trans
tienen una expectativa de vida entre 28
y 32 acá en el sur la expectativa de
vida es entre 35 y 40 años por lo tanto
vivir esta identidad de género vivir
como perteneciente a la comunidad el eje
de güímar es difícil es una contra de
lucha y pasa por estos temas de la
educación integral sexual en uruguay la
tenemos verdad tenemos educación
integral sexual donde se habla sobre la
diversidad de género donde se habla
sobre la diversidad sexual pero entonces
ahí aparecen grupos como por ejemplo
padres responsables donde desde según
ellos defienden el que se habla de
sexualidad en la casa el problema es que
no se educa en sexualidad en la casa y
por el otro lado
los conservadores confunden hablar de
diversidad sexual y diversidad de género
con hablar de sexo y la sexualidad
estamos hablando todo el tiempo porque a
ver si yo digo en este momento me fui
con mi novio a la playa a descansar y
estoy hablando de mi orientación sexual
pero no es hablar de lo que sucede en
cuatro paredes entonces los
conservadores usan esto para decir que
le vamos a enseñar a niños y niñas a ser
homosexuales a ser lesbianas a ser trans
nada más alejado de esto en uruguay está
comprobadísimo que la educación sexual
logró que personas atrás se dieran a la
educación logró bajar el embarazo
adolescente logró por ejemplo
concientizarse de la violencia sexual
tiene la educación sexual logra cosas y
no es
sexual no es únicamente hablar de la
identidad de género o de la orientación
sexual
hay una amplia gama yo soy docente yo
soy profesora de literatura en la
educación secundaria es hablar de una
trama de lm soy el problema así el poder
el problema es que si empezamos a
trabajar la educación sexual empezamos a
trabajar con leyes que reconozcan
nuestros derechos y siempre digo si una
sociedad necesita este tipo de leyes y
hay que interpelar si como sociedad es
porque la sociedad no está bien no le
está reconociendo derechos a otra parte
de la sociedad
para desacreditar ya vamos a hablar de
la parte de las leyes y los avances que
ha logrado la región en ese campo quiero
que natacha también intervenga en este
tema para cerrarlo ya y ponerle punto
final
natasha allí en costa rica y general
en centroamérica que tanto se habla que
tanto se educa
desafortunadamente así es el ministerio
de educación había tratado de generar
guías de educación en afectividad y
sexualidad pero es precisamente por toda
esta esta intervención que hay de grupos
fundamentalistas religiosos anti
derechos éste no se le permite acceder
al estudiantado a esta educación en la
medida en que bien lo decía este college
en la medida que podamos acceder a una
educación en sexualidad es este hablando
de una forma amplia de una forma veraz
con todos los datos y no esté con esas
tergiversaciones que se hacen de
nuestras temáticas no tendríamos por qué
estar luchando por ver con nuestros
derechos porque la sociedad en general
ya tendría conciencia de que los
derechos de nuestras poblaciones son los
derechos de toda la ciudadanía en la
medida en que se genere esta conciencia
que se logre generar una conciencia que
será la gran lucha no aun lado
hola por qué los países puente con
legislación específica que pueda generar
una mejor calidad de vida para las
poblaciones este es cuando tendremos una
sociedad más justa y equitativa para
llevar a mí mi siguiente tema de la
parte legislativa natasha colletti tal
vez voy a lanzar la pregunta muy muy
genérica muy muy general para que
ustedes puedan enfocar la por el lado
que lo consideren más pertinente y es el
balance que pueden hacer ustedes hasta
ahora hasta el 2021 en la parte de las
leyes que protegen a este colectivo que
tipifique la violencia que tipifiquen la
discriminación también que le permita a
la comunidad trans que tal vez es la más
afectada dentro del colectivo ya ustedes
lo mencionaban las cifras no son
alentadoras en cuanto a violencia contra
este este segmento del colectivo del egb
t
y también la esperanza de vida es muy
baja que tanto se ha avanzado en materia
de leyes y que se puede hacer en el
futuro cercano es decir qué leyes vamos
a poder ver pronto en los parlamentos de
los diferentes países por lo menos
siendo debatidas por lo menos siendo
discutidas y por lo menos el colectivo
impulsando allí mejorar y darle un poco
más de garantías a algunos sectores al
interior vamos con una talla aquí
gracias a lo que es este si bien como
usted lo decía tanto oliver como yo
somos parte de países que se pueden
llamar privilegiados porque contamos con
algunas ganando algunas ciertas
garantías y la gran mayoría de los
países de la región no cuentan con ni
siquiera regulaciones legislaciones
específicas para nuestras poblaciones un
ejemplo es el leyes de identidad de
género que permitan a las personas trans
acceder a un documento de identidad que
refleje su identidad y su expresión de
género y esto es medular en la garantía
de otros derechos porque a partir de eso
las personas trans pueden acceder a una
mejor educación a la salud a la vivienda
a la participación política a tantos
otros derechos a los que pueden acceder
el resto son ciudadanas y ciudadanas
aunado a eso también en la población
trans tiene gran necesidad de que se
añadieron también políticas públicas a
favor del empleo y empleabilidad este
porque la sociedad en general orilla
sobre todo a las mujeres trans a lo que
yo llamo sexo por sobrevivencia yo ni
siquiera lo llamaría trabajo sexual
porque es un trabajo generalmente se
cuenta con garantías con sueldos con
pensiones pero es lo que pasa con la
mayoría de las de las mujeres trans es
decir que existe una cadena de
marginación que empieza en el seno
familiar donde son echadas de sus casas
el sistema educativo tampoco las acoge
este no hay trabajo no hay otro tipo de
trabajo si la sociedad por una cuestión
de embudo generalmente olilla a las
mujeres tratadas a este sexo por
sobrevivencia la unidad que podamos
garantizar estos derechos fundamentales
yo creo que éste
podríamos garantizar una mejor
expectativa de vida no sólo para las
personas trans y muchas otras
poblaciones se podrían ver beneficiadas
también por estos derechos
colette su opinión
bueno a ver uruguay es uno de los países
que por ejemplo tiene el trabajo sexual
es legal el cambio de nombre en la
asistencia en salud todo lo harás ahora
mi pregunta siempre es la ley está
luchamos por las leyes defendemos las
leyes las defendemos contra los
discursos de odio
pero qué sucede con esas leyes cuando en
realidad la aplicación de esas leyes no
es lo que se está negando en esto que yo
planteaba y en la ley del presupuesto no
será presupuesto para
la salud por ejemplo todas las personas
trans no van a poder acceder a la salud
que pasa en general en latinoamérica y
caribe y natasha acá es una gran experta
en el tema también es que los gobiernos
latinoamérica yo lo decía recién ha
tenido una un avance impresionante en
las religiones más conservadoras del neo
pentecostalismo de las derechas
políticas más conservadoras unidas a los
militares todo eso
también una moral y una moral de
rectitud y una y un es señalar a
expulsar asesinar vulnerar a todo
aquello que no se adecue a su moral
porque porque vuelvo a repetir lo que
dijo hoy le rompemos su discurso como se
sostiene un discurso religioso si
aparece el aire
atrás legalizada si iba a decir algo iba
a añadir no era sólo para complementar
lo que está diciendo köhler que ahora
últimamente también se están uniendo
este grupos radicales feministas que de
un center
de la población trans sobre todo
rápidamente otro tema que quiero tocar
con ustedes es el tema del matrimonio
igualitario ya lo estaba mencionando la
introducción que chile está avanzando
están estudiando el proyecto de ley que
es impulsado por el mismo gobierno
bolivia pues ya está validando también
las uniones civiles que no es lo mismo
que un matrimonio pero es un paso sobre
todo para una sociedad tan conservadora
como la boliviana como ven ustedes el
panorama del matrimonio igualitario que
para muchos es como la gran medalla de
oro a conseguir pero es que es tal vez
un primer paso de una escalera muy
grande de muchos otros pasos hacia
arriba comienzo entonces con colette en
montevideo
bueno
cuando cuando hablamos de matrimonio y
cuando se plantea en cada país la el
tema del matrimonio igualitario
entonces otra vez salen las iglesias a
hablar salen los conservadores y el
matrimonio como lo sagrado y la realidad
es que hoy vivimos en una sociedad donde
la minoría de las personas se casan y la
minoría de las personas que conviven en
matrimonios felices durante muchos años
cuando el uruguay salió se aprobó el
matrimonio igualitario todo el mundo
pensaba que la gente iba a ir corriendo
a pasarse y no no pero también hay una
diferencia dentro de nuestra propia
comunidad y es quien aspira al
matrimonio igualitario y si nosotros lo
abrimos en las estadísticas son mucho
más los varones gays que sé que es que
se casan que la mujer es lesbiana y en
una íntima ínfima parte las personas
trans entonces también ahí tiene que ver
con las aspiraciones y el matrimonio
igualitario es pongo la bandera para
romper con toda esta cultura
conservadora soy ahora
y esto que vos decías la unión el
reconocimiento de la unión civil fue el
primer paso que en uruguay se dio para
que después viniese el matrimonio
igualitario para no entrar de lleno con
el matrimonio te piensa primero en la
unión civil es un primer paso la talla
su opinión
bueno es que básicamente bien donde dice
cuál es este a veces tiende a pensar que
ese acrónimo de lg vete y más tenemos
las mismas prioridades y no todas las
poblaciones de esta actualidad pero
mismo tenemos las mismas prioridades tal
vez por alguna parte de este compendio
de letras el matrimonio sea la prioridad
para otras como le digo este es el
derecho a la identidad y para otras este
que de la que no hemos hablado el día de
hoy como la población intersex este
derecho a la autonomía y la integridad
corporal que se decisión de hacer
cirugías no consentidas a niños y niñas
intersex como en este el matrimonio es
apenas una parte de los de los derechos
que se merecen las poblaciones el gp y
pumas hay muchos otros derechos por los
que tenemos que seguir luchando son
éstas apenas uno de los tantos derechos
y que no tendremos que estar luchando
porque somos tan tan ciudadanos y
ciudadanas como cualquier otra persona
no tendríamos por qué estar luchando por
ciudadanos de los cuales gozan
es tan claro me quedan pocos minutos
para cerrar el programa quiero cerrar
con el balance que hacen ustedes
el colectivo frente a la pandemia de
kobe 19 veíamos escenarios un poco
absurdos como por ejemplo en panamá que
para ayudar en el confinamiento pues
decretaron esto del pico y generó y
generó muchísima controversia no
solamente panamá sino en otros países de
la región y generó mucha controversia en
el colectivo qué balance hacen ustedes
de la relación que ha tenido el
colectivo con el manejo que se le ha
dado a la pandemia y que ha dejado
muchas cosas de lado cosas muy
importantes como por ejemplo los
medicamentos y la atención para los
pacientes que tienen vih y que tienen
algún tipo de problema de salud
importante rápidamente para el cierre en
la talla permite gracias
[Música]
esto de la pandemia este para muchas de
las poblaciones no es algo nuevo ya
muchas de las poblaciones ya vivíamos en
pandemia ya vivíamos en pobreza entre
greg acción y marginación entonces lo
que vino a demostrar la pandemia hoy fue
agravar la situación de muchas de estas
de nuestras poblaciones y perdonen que
me refiera tanto a la población trans y
la población intersex pero es la que más
me atraviesa el cuerpo la que más con
los entonces vino a grabar precisamente
situaciones que ya eran precarios en
nuestras poblaciones
los delitos de suicidio en población
trans e intersex han crecido mucho
tengo que interrumpe lo que se marca al
programa y quiero conocerla
el cierre que le puede dar coleta a esta
conversación rápidamente colette por
favor de la pandemia y no a demostrar
la pobreza multidimensional que vive en
nuestras poblaciones en especial también
la población trans la población de hay
pobre la población de lesbianas hombres
indígenas afrodescendientes sí y ahí fue
donde tuvimos que salir las
organizaciones de la sociedad civil a
estar presentes donde los gobiernos
están ausentes claro con la ayuda
sanitaria con el apoyo psicoemocional o
sea enfrentar violencia sea una cara de
cólera
muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado se nos acaba el tiempo aquí
en el debate de france 24 un gusto
gracias por este debate y a ustedes
gracias por la sintonía
[Música]